Oh, thank you.
This is the Chris Abraham Show.
Hey there, this is Chris Abraham
from The Chris Abraham Show,
Episode 5 and no season five
Episode 32.
Bente dos no trente dos trente
idos.
Anyway, I don't know any
languages.
I know 32 so.
I was thinking about this weird
condition I have.
I'm actually going to the doctor
this really super specialist,
but that's not what this is
about.
I'm going to a specialist called
an electrocardio
electrocardiologist or whatever,
and his job is to wonder why I
have A fib, but I haven't had
A-fib in a few months and I'm
walking over this tree and I'm
knocking on wood.
And I feel like I might be out
of the woods.
Like I felt so overconfident
today that I had a Big Breakfast
and a pot of coffee.
So that'll be realistic
experience.
That's what I do.
So it's not like I'm trying to
scan the doctor like I usually
do and everybody usually does
so.
But that's not about this.
I'm just going to walk up to
Idido's coffee shop, my favorite
coffee shop, and record this
episode on the way and then get
my Uber from there because it's
like gonna be a $50 round trip
because the doctors weigh the F
out.
And I was going to cancel the
the appointment because I'm
feeling good, but I don't want
to go ahead and play like that,
so.
I'm talking about A Fantasia
today and S dam and these are
two conditions I didn't know I
had till I was 50 and I'm self
diagnosed.
But it all makes sense because
when I was watching the TV show
on Netflix Amazon called Space
Force there was a scene where
one of the guards.
On the Space Force grounds was
flirting with the daughter of
the commander general of the
Space Force and she was making I
don't remember now, but she was
making comments about
visualizing and he said I can't
visualize I have a Fantasia.
And then at that exact moment a
million people from around the
country looked up a Fantasia and
discovered that they.
Didn't have a mind's eye and
they didn't know that.
They didn't have it because you
only know what you know.
And then to find out that the
only reason I became a
literature major, I believe,
aside from like the obvious
thing, which is the inability to
memorize in terms of.
Flash cards that I can refer to
in my mind's eye.
Let's assume that I'm smarter
than that.
The reason why I did it is
because I was so impressed as to
how poetic languages.
But it's not poetic.
People are just literally the
language isn't.
Poetic People have magical
visualization skills in Marcel
Post or Proust or Proust or post
Marcel Post.
He literally, when he bit into
that Madeleine cookie, he
literally, figuratively was
thrown into a rabbit hole of his
own memories, his own visual
experiential memorial like
taste, smell, sight, everything.
Like there was a comprehensive.
All 12 senses experience of
memories that he had that were
catalyzed by this Madeleine
cookie and a lot of people have
that.
My best friend has extreme it's
called hyper Fantasia where you
can go ahead and he can do CAD
Cam in his head and and his
brain also lies like I'm like do
a do a CAD Cam.
Of a 911 Porsche.
And he totally could.
But he doesn't know what the
undercarriage of a Porsche is.
He doesn't know what the
dashboard of a 911 looks like.
He didn't ask me what year.
He didn't ask me automatic or
manual or tiptronic or double
clutch.
He didn't ask me any of those
things.
He didn't ask me what color
leather.
He didn't ask me What Car.
His imagination just makes shit
up.
And fills in the blanks with
lies.
So anyway, the reason why I
bring this up today is because I
was watching this comedian and
she was talking about how new
girlfriends are extremely
generous to their new men
because they know that the men
are.
The men are dealing with new
bodies, new women.
They've been trained up by other
ladies.
And that they're working on
figuring out if this man has
sexual potential and he his his
sexual performance is not based
on the first time.
So women give men a lot of rope
and and then one of the things
she said is that you know, she's
like we all fake our first
orgasm.
All that moaning you do, you
hear us do, is to try to train
you as to how close and how far
you are from being good.
I think that might be Air Force
or whatever.
Marine One.
I feel like that's the Marine
One helicopter that you hear.
And then the third thing, which
is most salient germane of this
conversation, is.
She said the third thing is that
we're imagining other people,
right?
Like, I wonder how much how much
of a part of sex is imagining
other people?
Because the biggest thing in my
entire life that people cannot
handle when I tell them that I
literally cannot visualize
anything in my head.
And when I try, all I see is
black, like darkness, like when
you close your eyes.
And you don't have a thought.
I the biggest thing is that they
when they realize that I can't
visualize another person when
I'm having sex and then I've
never been able to do that and I
need to date someone who who who
arouses me completely.
Because I have no alternative.
The person I'm looking at is
literally the person I'm making
love to.
I'm never thinking about someone
else.
I'm never visualizing someone
I'm never wishing I was
somewhere else.
Like if I'm not sexually and
physically presently attracted
to you through eyes, ears, nose,
and throat, then.
Honestly, the only way we can
have sex is with Viagra, right?
Because like, like, I cannot
visualize someone else if you
don't arouse me and I don't have
a deep desire to make a dissuite
to love with you, I I There's
nothing I can do about it,
right?
I can do stuff that doesn't.
I can do a lot of stuff, but I
can't do the stuff that really
gets me into it unless I'm.
Physically attracted to the
human being in front of me.
I can be attracted to the idea
of that person I could be
attracted to, that the sexy
personality I could be attracted
to just, you know, a certain
part, certain parts.
I can be intoxicated by a
situation or a smell.
I can.
I can be attracted to bottoms
and boobs and bellies and legs
and toes and hands and clavicles
and necks and faces, but you are
all I have to feed from.
I cannot eat of you.
And then imagine chicken
frickacy.
I don't know.
Boof bourguignon.
I cannot.
I cannot make it to sweet love
with you.
And then imagine you know, 80s
Cindy Crawford SO or 80s Paulina
Poroscova or whomever so say to
say to.
Anyway, I just thought I'd share
that with you.
I don't know how comprehensive
or complete the reproduction of
Ryan Reynolds or.
Whomever, in your imagination,
how much it can make up for all
that.
I don't know if you can replace
full on everything down to kind
of an experiential replacement,
sexual replacement or love
making replacement where you're
literally on top of Ryan
Reynolds or or or Sofia.
Sofia Gaga, Gaga, Gaga or or,
you know, 80s, Cindy Crawford or
or whomever.
But I've never been able to do
that.
Like if I'm not looking at a
picture or looking at you or
looking at someone else.
Like I wonder if if men who
married women out of
expectation, familiar
expectation.
Are able to visualize being with
a man or I don't even know what
the magical powers are of this
thing known as hyper
visualization.
I know it's on a spectrum and I
hear that people who have
completely blacked out mind's
eye like I do is less than 1%.
But I feel like since it's a
spectrum there are a lot of low.
I wonder if it's racial or
gender based or ethnic or
whatever.
But anyway, there you have it.
I'm walking through a
construction site now, so I
don't think that this is the
best time to continue talking.
So I love you guys.
I hope you're having fun and
I'll talk to you soon.
If you have any questions, let
me know.
Smooches and booches.
Bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.